[Applause]
Alessandra Ambrosio is officially
hanging up her angel wings the angels
take over Shanghai China for the 2017
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show airing
November 28th on CBS only ET was
backstage where Alessandra exclusively
revealed she's retiring from modeling in
the annual show victory seekers my
family but you know it's time to move on
you know 17 times I'm like mom is tired
the supermodel took the runway for the
last time and had the cutest fan in her
cheering section I got to see my
daughter as I was walking and it was
just so cute I actually brought her
backstage so she got to hang with all my
angel friends and with everyone she
loves it she loves all that you know and
just to see my whole family there
cheering for me and she's like almost
jumping out it was so cute her daughter
Anja dancing at the after-party was even
cuter
tune into et tonight to find out what's
next for Alessandra and how she plans on
celebrating the end of an era I love
everyone you know here they're my family
they'll always be my family